hey everyone is fares register nurse Ari
and Doc home and in this video we're
going to be going over our weekly
inquest
practice question and don't forget to
check out the other practice questions
in this series so let's see what our
question says a patient who has a health
history of uncontrolled hypertension
coronary artery disease and diabetes
mellitus is prescribed to take
propanolol you have reverted the patient
with education about this new medication
which statement by the patient indicates
your teaching was effective a I will
take this medication every morning with
grapefruit juice B if I miss a dose it
is important that I double the next dose
to prevent potential side-effects C is
important that I monitor my blood
glucose level very closely while taking
this medication or D I will immediately
stop taking this medication if I
experience cold hands or feet so for
this particular question it is wanting
to know which statement by the patient
is correct about this medication propel
wall that they're going to be taking so
we're looking at the correct statement
so out of all these three are going to
be wrong and one is going to be correct
so before we do that let's analyze this
scenario now as you read the scenario
some things should be jumping out at you
for instance the patient's health
history and they have a history of
uncontrolled hypertension which is high
blood pressure they also have coronary
artery disease and diabetes mellitus now
let's talk about that drug propanolol
that's what they're prescribed now let's
think back to pharmacology this is the
generic name of the drug generic names
tend to have the same letters for the
ending and the ending for this is Oh lol
with drugs in an oh lol these are our
beta-blockers so prepare well is a
beta-blocker now it falls under the
non-selective category there are several
groups of beta-blockers you have ones
that act on just that heart tissue
specifically their beta 1 receptor
blockers and then you have these which
acts on both the beta 1 and beta 2
receptors
now let's backtrack and talk about what
beta blockers do let's review in our
pharmacology because it's going to make
sense when we're throwing in that this
patient has diabetes mellitus because
whenever you have diabetes mellitus and
you're taking a beta blocker you have to
watch out for some certain things that
can happen okay so what about a walkers
do internet film beta blockers block
your sympathetic nervous system what
does your sympathetic nervous system do
it is responsible for that
fight-or-flight response so whenever
you're stressed you're in danger
that system kicks in it increases your
heart rate so you get tachycardia you
get bronchodilation so you're going to
breathe deeper so you can run away and
get out of there now
non-selective which is propanolol it
blocks beta receptors one and two
remember now we're our beta 1 receptors
they're mainly in your heart so whenever
you take this drug and acts on those
neurotransmitters specifically
norepinephrine and epinephrine so those
will be blocked and in the heart and
what will happen is that you will get a
slower heart rate instead of that
tachycardia
now think about diabetes mellitus
whenever these patients have
hypoglycemia
what are those classic signs and
symptoms one of the most classic sign
and symptom is tachycardia their heart
rate goes up how a lot of patients tell
me my heart rates increased we might
need to check my sugar I feel like it's
down now if they're taking a beta
blocker that is blocking that response
they're not going to have that classic
tachycardia so they may later on there
sugar will drop so much and it may be
too late before they cannot treat it
before they can treat it appropriately
now beta 2 receptors where are these
mainly located they are located in
various places number one your lungs you
have two lungs at I remember beta 2 they
can also be in the skeletal muscle acts
in the liver one thing I want to
concentrate on is that liver and the
muscle now what these beta receptors do
they increase a process called
glycogenolysis what is that big old word
what it means is that whenever a patient
has hypoglycemia the body tries to
correct that so it will do
glycogenolysis which is going to break
down glycogen to glucose which is going
to increase that blood sugar however
this is being blocked in this patient
this process is slowing it down so when
this diabetic has hypoglycemia they're
not going to be able to increase that
blood sugar naturally with that process
so you have this double-edged sword you
have where they're not going to be able
to notice their blood glucose because
they don't have that tachycardia going
on and they don't have that process of
increasing that blood sugar naturally
themselves so those two things are going
to be blocked now let's look at our
options you've probably already figured
out the option based on what we just
discussed with that and looking at these
but let's break them down and discuss
why they're wrong okay
option a I will take the medication
every morning with grapefruit juice okay
big thing that jumps out at me
grapefruit juice why would a patient
want to take medication with grapefruit
juice all the time one thing that was
always drilled in my head in nursing
school is never take grapefruit juice
okay with beta blockers specifically you
don't want to take Medicaid this type of
medication or various medications with
grapefruit juice because grapefruit
juice contains chemicals that can slow
the absorption of the medication so the
patient wouldn't want to take their beta
blockers with grapefruit juice I need
educated to actually avoid that and just
take it strictly with water so this is
wrong
option B says if I miss a dose it is
important that I double the next dose to
prevent potential side-effects if a
patient misses a dose of their beta
blockers they don't need to double the
dose they need to take it as soon as
they remember unless that next doses do
because these medications as we talked
about with the beta blockers and they
decrease your heart rate they do a lot
of things to your heart and if you're
taking double the dose they are a high
risk of a cardiac event going into some
lethal rhythm so that is incorrect
option C talking about monitoring your
blood glucose levels very closely and I
just discussed why that is our answer
because the way the beta one the beta 2
receptors work with the maintain the
blood glucose and the patient is already
diabetic taking insulin probably that's
what we assumed and so they have to
monitor their blood sugar especially
with these non-selective beta blockers
so that is our answer now let's look and
see why D is wrong this patient says
that they're going to stop taking their
beta blocker immediately if they
experience cold hands and feet well this
is a normal side effect with these
non-selective beta blockers because
remember they're not just acting on that
cardiac tissue they're acting on other
areas and a lot of patients I've had
actually report my hands are so cold
since I started taking this drug my feet
so this is actually a side effect that
can happen and another thing that makes
this statement wrong is that you would
never just immediately stop taking a
beta blocker
they need to be tapered off of this
because if they just all of a sudden
quit taking that medication they can go
have cardiac death or something worst
can happen so that answer is wrong for
or that reason okay so that wraps up
this NCLEX practice question be sure to
check out our other ink lex lectures and
quizzes and nursing skills videos thank
you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos